con antorchas y velas encendidas
activistas en ser lanka rinden homenaje
a las personas que murieron durante los
meses de protestas contra el gobierno
del país vivo
beta olvida que debo decir que sin su
ayuda no hubiéramos podido alcanzar esta
victoria realmente habríamos fracasado
sin su concluirlo
es una victoria que los manifestantes
todavía están celebrando la renuncia del
derrocado presidente gotabaya rajapaksa
provocó euforia entre los manifestantes
que los señalan de una mala gestión
económica y de corrupción rajapaksa ha
defendido su historial y culpa de la
crisis económica a la pandemia una
excusa con la que no evitó críticas
ahora si es blanca está preparándose
para un nuevo capítulo político después
de que el primer ministro run y louie
cremes inge se convirtiera en presidente
interino el viernes pasado esto antes de
que el parlamento elija un nuevo líder
el 20 de julio con el respaldo del
partido del gobierno del ex presidente
hui créeme zinc es el favorito para
ganar la votación pero es un escenario
que los manifestantes quieren evitar
one the battle of the end in gorda
verdad ganamos la batalla de enviar a
casa a gotabhaya rajapakse ganaremos la
batalla final de sacar al primer
ministro y también ganaremos toda la
guerra a nivel de bóveda en tie volver
desde hace meses sir lanka atraviesa por
su peor crisis económica en siete
décadas la inestabilidad ha enviado a
miles de manifestantes a las calles
durante meses mientras los habitantes
luchan por lidiar con la escasez de
bienes básicos la gasolina y la
desenfrenada inflación en el país